das ist das nigerdelta und in den
aber wenden wir diese theorien doch mal
von co2 werden zum beispiel euro
video hier ist in zusammenarbeit mit dem
vielleicht ist das ein bisschen
eigenen vorteil bedacht ein altes
beide gestehen die staatsanwaltschaft
kriegen wir das alles klar man kann den
pessimismus aber ich gehe irgendwie
monatlichen beiträge in eine vielzahl an
auf unsere realen probleme an die wir
youtube kanal klimaneutral entstanden
letzten 50 jahren haben dort
klischee ohne eine reduzierung der
klagt beide an fordert aber nicht die
schätzungsweise zwei millionen tonnen
meistens davon aus dass menschen eher an
jetzt gerade haben wir müssen am besten
zum heutigen earth day wollten wir
eigenen konsum überdenken bewusster und
umweltschutz projekten investiert
höchststrafe weil ihr beide mit dem
rohöl das ökosystem massiv beschädigt
co2-emissionen wird unser planet eines
sich selbst denken wenn jeder an sich
gemeinsam ein video über die klimakrise
nachhaltiger lieben aber ein
daneben habe die in der klima app jetzt
schon vorgestern kooperieren co2
staat kooperieren und möglichkeit nummer
machen nur eben ohne diese typische
maßgeblicher teil der globalen
selbst denkt ist an alle gedacht wie
auch die möglichkeit bei euch
tages unbewohnbar wo alles immer wieder
darunter leiden als erstes die bewohner
emissionen weltweit einsparen aber wir
3 einer von euch beiden gesteht die
erderwärmung liegt nicht in der hand des
ausführlich über alternative
moralkeule zu schwingen oder zum
kann das dann also sein wenn wir doch
der region auf jahrzehnte lange sicht
möglichkeiten zum klimaschutz zu
einzelnen außer jemand von euch ist sie
kurzfristige kompromisse gab dieses
tun es nicht warum zum einen ist an die
von natur aus eher altruistisch
hundertsten mal dieselben tipps zu
staatsanwaltschaft klagt den anderen an
bringt aber wieder die verschmutzung
informieren es gibt zum beispiel eine
wiederholen die ja eigentlich jeder
eingestellt sind nun ja die regeln
auf einem großen ölkonzernen
und dieser bekommt die höchststrafe zehn
noch der co2 ausstoß durch die
eigens produzierte video reihe die euch
tatsache dass vorsorge ein bisschen
kennt und heraus kamen dieses video hier
bundeskanzler oder in irgendeiner
ölförderung irgendjemandem was nicht mal
jahre der bestehende für dafür aber
machen das spiel so lange sich egoismus
mit hilfreichen tipps für einen
undankbar ist wer regelmäßig zum
ein video über psychologie und games
anderen form ein wichtiger
nachhaltigeren alltag versorgt außerdem
freigelassen jetzt ist die frage ob ihr
entscheidungsträger oder eine wichtige
lohnt wird es menschen geben die das
den verantwortlichen ölkonzernen aber
zahnarzt geht der erspart sich jetzt
theorie und alles mögliche wie man
spannend ihr habt jetzt die option über
allgemeinwohl hinten anstellen trotzdem
entscheidungsträgerinnen als normale
beide ohne die entscheidung des anderen
eine eigene griffe und schmerzen
trotzdem passiert so etwas wie die
entscheidungen trifft wenn euch intensiv
die klima app eurem lokalen abgeordneten
trotzdem machen das super viele menschen
verschmutzung im nigerdelta ja immer
zu kennen kooperiert um eine geringere
bürgerinnen oder bürger kann man nicht
dürfen natürlich nicht vergessen dass
mit dem thema klima und klimakrise
im bundestag zu schreiben und können so
viel tun außer zu kooperieren du und ich
noch jeden tag überall auf der erde also
nicht so lange die zähne nicht wehtun
die spieltheorie wie ist der name schon
auseinandersetzen wollte dann empfehle
strafe zu bekommen oder ob einer von
ganz direkt mehr und schnelleren
ich euch sehr den kanal klimaneutral zu
sagt theoretisch ist entscheidungen sind
wird einem eben nicht deutlich wie
euch den anderen in die pfanne haut
haben keine verantwortung den
warum treffen wir menschen solche
wichtig vorsorge ist aber irgendwann tut
abonnieren denn dort gibt es jede woche
klimaschutz fordern wenn ihr beim
sobald ihr aber beide egoistisch handelt
klimawandel alleine auf unseren
mehr als nur mathematik und sehr komplex
egoistischen entscheidungen die
sehr gut recherchierte und
schultern zu tragen aber eben die
einrichten der app unseren kopf benutzt
es dann doch wie und dann ist es
gibt es nur verlierer so zeigt die games
langfristig total dumm sind und wie
faktenbasierte videos danke für die sehr
dann unterstützt ihr damit unseren kanal
deutlich teurer alles wieder hinzubiegen
möglichkeit alles in unserer macht zu
theorie etwas sehr spannendes
und können gleichzeitig auch noch zehn
gute beispiele hierfür sind die
spiel theoretischen berechnung zieht
tun man kann seinen abgeordneten
können wir die spielregeln so verändern
gute zusammenarbeit und jetzt gehts los
kooperation also in dem fall beide sagen
sind keine abbildung der realität aber
extra bäume spenden geht dafür einfach
flutkatastrophe oder die pandemie
dass die richtigen entscheidungen
mit dem video menschen sind ganz schön
schreiben man kann freitags die schule
getroffen werden genau darum geht es
nichts lohnt sich insgesamt bekommt ihr
skippen für den klimastreit und man kann
sie helfen themen zu vereinfachen und
den code dr watson in der app ein und
irgendwann sehen wir wahrscheinlich auch
heute bei dr immer zunächst auf seinen
kompliziert
in regelmäßigen abständen wählen gehen
alle ein dass die klimakatastrophe jeden
dementsprechend verkopft und irrational
so nur sechs monate haftstrafe anstatt
dadurch zu verstehen zum beispiel den
falls ihr euch noch nicht ganz sicher
sein ob die app wirklich hält was sie
wer für uns wichtige politische
betrifft aber bisher merkt man im alltag
der sonst zehn jahre individuell gesehen
sind eine menge entscheidungen die wir
klimawandel passend dazu ist auch der
entscheidungen treffen soll und je
verspricht dann kann euch vielleicht
jeden tag treffen ich kann zum beispiel
davon nur wenig dazu kommt den
dieses video hier helfen da haben wir
größer die gruppe an menschen mit denen
neue pc bericht von anfang april um die
lohnt es sich aber egoistisch zu handeln
selber nicht wirklich logisch herleiten
man hier zusammen kooperiert desto
uns kritisch mit der app und dem thema
klimawandel einzugrenzen ist eine
entweder komme ich frei oder ich bekomme
warum ich gestern doch schokolade
klimakatastrophe aufzuhalten brauchen
of setting im allgemeinen
globale team leistung die wir als
größer ist der einfluss auf die
auseinandergesetzt insgesamt halte ich
zumindest nur die zweithöchste
gekauft habe obwohl ich ja eigentlich
menschheit erbringen müssen noch ziehen
entscheidungsträger irgendwann werden
wir systematisch veränderungen schreiben
haftstrafe wenn ich aussage wenn ich
nur gemüse gebraucht habe aber hey das
aber jede form von aktivität und gutem
wir aber lange nicht alle am selben
die wissenschaftler da also ganz schön
alle verstehen dass die klimakrise kein
strang was natürlich für das gefühl
hingegen schweige gehe ich definitiv ins
willen für super und deswegen hier
macht uns menschen eben aus oder die
nationales problem ist sondern die
krass die spielregeln der gesellschaft
sorgen kann dass es nichts bringt wenn
gefängnis vielleicht sogar mit der
nochmal vielen dank an alle die sich die
menschen sind impulsiv und nicht immer
menschheit als ganzes betrifft nur dann
höchststrafe
zum beispiel nur deutschland komplett
und vor allem wirtschaft müssen laut dem
app bereits heruntergeladen haben um
rational
egal was mein partner in crime macht ich
gleichzeitig ist das aber auch super
co2 neutral wird abgesehen davon dass ja
könnte es schon zu spät sein aber
bericht neu gedacht werden weil aktuell
einen unterschied zu machen und damit
anstrengend wenn wir an die großen
alleine komme immer besser weg wenn ich
resignation ist auf jeden fall nicht
zum thema eine zweite möglichkeit neben
irgendwer anfangen muss ist es hier
kurzfristige gewinne belohnt werden die
probleme der zukunft denken ist es
meinen kompanien an kreider nur soweit
angebracht denn auch beim
wichtig zu erwähnen der einfluss
extrem wichtig welche entscheidungen
uns aber langfristig die existenz kosten
positive anerkennung ist so ein bisschen
temperaturanstieg gilt schlimmer geht
alle so handeln lohnt es sich für keinen
deutschlands auf den klimawandel wird
das gegenteil nämlich der 2 wir als
menschen hier und jetzt treffen umso
werden okay die zielrichtung ist also
oft unterschätzt deutschland ist für
mehr also kooperation ist king aber
immer die forschung sagt aktuell sieht
1,77 prozent der weltweiten co2
entscheidender dass wir verstehen wie
klar aber wie machen wir das eine
gesellschaft haben irgendwann mal
es unglaublich scheiße aus aber das
entschieden dass wir diejenigen die
und warum wir entscheidungen treffen
emissionen verantwortlich und ja oft
warum arbeiten wir dann nicht alle
heißt nicht dass wir es nicht doch
beliebte methode um kooperation zu
nicht mitspielen wollen teilweise mit
zusammen ob wir in bestimmten
und hier gibt es eine ziemlich spannende
wird dann gesagt dass es andere länder
schaffen können in diesem sinne bleibt
fördern ist anerkennung menschen spenden
theorie nicht aus der psychologie und
situationen nur an uns selbst denken
gibt die jetzt gerade für viel mehr
hilfe von strafen zur kooperation
neugierig und gibt die hoffnung nicht
meist bereitwilliger wenn sie auch eine
oder auch an andere ist kompliziert aber
emissionen sorgen aber die 1,77 prozent
aus der soziologie sondern aus der
zwingen so funktionieren zum beispiel
auf
entsprechende anerkennung dafür erhalten
mathematik die game theory und was man
es gibt hinweise darauf dass uns eine
lassen historische emissionen außen vor
auch im ganz normalen alltag hilft man
steuern kurzfristig gesehen findet
der beiden verhaltensweisen mehr liegt
mit der games theorie ganz schnell sieht
zum beispiel dem freund beim umzug
wir haben die zeit der großen
als die andere noch bis vor kurzer zeit
natürlich jeder steuern durch
wir menschen sind ganz schön schlecht
lieber wenn er sich danach bedankte oder
industrialisierung und viele emissionen
langfristig profitieren wir aber davon
darin abzuschätzen was für uns
waren sich forschende sicher dass der
schon hinter uns gelassen andere länder
vielleicht sogar eine pizza spendiert
weil damit die straße gebaut wird auf
langfristig besser ist ein beispiel
mensch von natur aus egoistisch ist aber
und genau diese erkenntnis will ich
der ich fahre oder die schule finanziert
noch nicht rechnet man die mit ein dann
jetzt mal anwenden danke danke an die
stellt euch vor ihr habt zusammen mit
plot ist mittlerweile wurden diese
wird auf die ich meine kinder schicken
ist deutschland schon für 3,5 prozent an
einem freund oder einer freundin eine
theorien in der forschung widerlegt
die kooperation funktioniert aber nicht
co2 ausstoßes verantwortlich
vielen hundert doktor watson zuschauer
bank ausgeraubt und weil die besonders
alleine über die tollen versprechen was
tatsächlich scheint es so dass der
okay aber wie kriegen wir es hin dass
die sich schon die klima app
begabte bankräuber seid habt ihr fast
heruntergeladen haben und seitdem
mit meinem geld alles gemacht wird
mensch auf kooperation und gemeinschaft
wir kooperieren unsere kurzfristigen
keine spuren hinterlassen die
nachhaltiger leben falls ihr die app
sondern über die androhung von strafe
gepolt ist dafür gibt es gleich mehrere
ziele vergessen und anstelle dessen auf
staatsanwaltschaft weist zwar dass ihr
noch nicht kennt ihr könnt doch zum
wenn nicht zahlt bekommt stress mit dem
beispiel eure co2 emissionen ausgleichen
gründe erstens bringt altruismus also
es war aber es fehlen die entscheidenden
nachhaltigkeit setzen wie können wir
finanzamt und das wird ungemütlich gut
beweise ohne die wird das gewicht euch
aber auch tipps für ein nachhaltigeres
unser gesamtes system ändern ja das ist
zuerst an andere zu denken auch einen
leben holen und gemeinsam mit euren
nicht viel anhaben können es sei denn
wert für den einzelnen zum beispiel
freunden etwas gegen die klimakrise tun
eine frage für wahrscheinlich fünf
einer von euch beiden sagt aus jetzt
status und anerkennung und zweitens wie
doktor watson videos aber so viel kann
seit dem heutigen öfter am 22 april ist
sitzt er im verhör und steht vor der
ich schon mal sagen wir müssen wir
wahl bestehen oder nichtbestehen ein
viele wildtiere ist auch der mensch auf
die app neu aufgestellt und will die
kooperationen in der gruppe angewiesen
müssen kooperieren es geht nicht anders
zentrale anlaufstelle für nachhaltigkeit
zimmer weiter sitzt ihr komplize und die
ein mammut erlegt sich zum beispiel
wenn wir es nicht tun dann verlieren wir
in eurem leben werden beim of setting
staatsanwaltschaft schlägt euch
nicht von alleine und auch wenn man
folgenden deal form ihr habt drei
alle und das sagt nicht nur die games
games szenarien in aufwändigen
möglichkeiten möglichkeit nummer eins
theorie sondern auch viele viele
simulationen durchrechnet lohnt sich
führende wissenschaftlerinnen und
beide bleiben still die
kooperation auf lange sicht für den
wissenschaftler trotzdem die frage wie
staatsanwaltschaft klagt euch dann für
einzelnen am meisten schon der start so
kleinere delikte an und ihr bekommt eine
gerne mal dieses video hier vom youtube
geringe strafe möglichkeit nummer zwei
kanal primer an das fand ich wirklich
richtig gut dargestellt ok ich weiß
nicht wie es bei euch ist aber wir
fanden dass schon überraschend
[Musik]